herr lindner die zahl 50 und auch die
zahl 35 die stehen im § 28a
infektionsschutzgesetz hier im deutschen
bundestag beschlossen und sind insofern
nicht willkürlich und das in ihrer
behauptung der deutsche bundestag wäre
hier nicht beteiligt meine damen und
herren
wenn wir uns die entwicklung der letzten
wochen und monate angucken da muss man
sagen der locker und wirkt wir kommen
vor und instanzen vor neue
infektionszahlen von knapp 200 wir sind
jetzt unter 65 das heißt die maßnahmen
haben gewirkt und wir liegen übrigens
auch im europäischen vergleich mit
unseren neuinfektionen sehr sehr gut
besser als viele viele andere länder
besser als viele nachbarländer wir
liegen ja auch insgesamt noch sehr gut
bei der anzahl der infizierten auf
100000 einwohner und auch ja bei der
anzahl der toten auf 100000 einwohner
was schlecht ist das gehört zur wahrheit
leider auch dazu ist die anzahl der
toten bei den hochbetagten das ist eine
sache wo wir uns als gesellschaft fragen
müssen ob wir dort alles richtig gemacht
haben liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
meine damen und herren das war jetzt
sehr interessant jetzt sagt herr lindner
da muss die cdu sich fragen
also ich finde schon sehr sehr
interessant wie sie mit dieser krise
umgehen wie sie versuchen
parteipolitisches kapital zu schlagen
wie sie versuchen wahlkampf zu machen in
der schwersten krise wie diese republik
hat es ist erbärmlicher linda und die
bilder hin und wieder zeigen es ihnen
auch bei den umfragen dass das nicht
verfängt was sie hier veranstalten liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir sind beim thema impfen auch zu
langsam aber mittlerweile ins rollen
gekommen
und wir sind auch beim thema wirtschafts
hilfen und das muss man an dieser stelle
auch sagen viel viel umfangreicher
unterwegs als die meisten anderen länder
und ja herr mützenich da gehört auch das
kurzarbeitergeld dazu dazu gehörten
vereinfachter zugang bei hartz4 dazu es
ist ein gesamtpaket was wir im bereich
wirtschaft auf den weg gebracht haben
und es ist gut dass die
überbrückungshilfe drei jetzt auch
ausgezahlt wird liebe kolleginnen und co
und für all diejenigen die jetzt sagen
ja aber in anderen ländern ist es besser
ja andere länder haben andere umstände
australien ist eine insel und wir können
uns gerne mal die repressionsmaßnahmen
in china angucken ob wir die hier haben
wollen und im übrigen ist es so dass
andere länder auch nicht so viele
hochbetagte haben wie wir
aber eins ist auch richtig alle länder
die besser durch die panini gekommen
sind als wir haben zuerst einen
radikalen lockt onkel hatten und haben
zuerst die zahlen nach unten geknüppelt
nach unten geprügelt und deswegen ist es
auch richtig was wir hier machen dass
wir sagen bevor wir in differenzierte
maßnahmen einsteigen müssen wir erst die
zahlen nach unten kriegen und das ist
genau die politik die jetzt auch gestern
in der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
entsprechend weitergeführt wird und
diese politik die ist richtig liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und deswegen ist es auch heute zu
unterstützen dass die noch dauern
maßnahmen weitergeführt werden sorgen
bereitet mir allerdings auch wenn es in
unserem grundgesetz vorgesehen ist dass
die länder individuell darüber
entscheiden die schulen und die kitas
wieder zu öffnen
ich habe da meine zweifel ob das in
dieser phase richtig ist weil wenn wir
mal uns betrachten wo wir herkommen und
die bundeskanzlerin hat gesagt wir
kommen von instanzen unter 10 unter 5
und da müssen wir auch wieder hin um
entsprechend die öffnung hin zu kriegen
natürlich ist es sehr sehr hart für die
schülerinnen und schüler für die eltern
für die familien und das erkennen wir
auch anders es hat es essen ist eine
zumutung aber es ist auch eine zumutung
dass mehr als 60.000 menschen in diesem
land gestorben sind liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen oder auch das muss man
immer wieder im hinterkopf behalten will
dann über freiheitsrechte redet und ich
bleibe dabei herr lindner was ich hier
vor einigen wochen gesagt habe freiheit
ist auch immer die freiheit der
schwachen und nicht nur die freiheit der
starken über politik
und kollegen
aber wenn wir einmal nach vorne schauen
dann reicht das ja jetzt nicht dass
ministerpräsidenten dass das
bundeskabinett das wir hier uns klar
darüber sind wie es entsprechend weiter
geht sondern es gibt eine menge die noch
dinge die noch zu tun sind
ich möchte ihnen fünf dinge nennen wo
wir jetzt ran müssen das erste ist das
thema schulen ja es ist die
länderkompetenz aber trotzdem erwarte
ich gerade vor dem hintergrund dass
jetzt wieder hoffnungen auf den weg
gebracht werden test strategien lüftung
strategien logistik strategien dass die
schulbusse nicht mehr so voll sind beim
thema schulen erwarte ich dass es eine
lernstandserhebung gibt was ist verpasst
worden
das ist konzepte dafür gibt über den
sommer hinweg durch nachhilfe durch
sommerakademie wie dieser stoff
aufgeholt werden kann
das ist konzepte dafür gibt wie
insbesondere die kinder gefördert werden
die im benachteiligten familien
aufwachsen von nicht geholfen werden
kann liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
gehört natürlich auch dazu
ich glaube wir haben im bereich schule
sehr sehr viel zu tun
der zweite bereich gesundheitsämter das
rückgrat unserer pandemie bekämpfung
sind die gesundheitsämter ja wir haben
einen pakt für das öffentliche
gesundheitswesen ja wir haben mehr geld
bereitgestellt aber dieses geld muss
jetzt auch entsprechend umgesetzt werden
die software frage muss schnell gelöst
werden wir müssen die prozesse
analysieren und wir brauchen
monitoringstelle wo die qualität der
gesundheitsämter auch tatsächlich
kontrolliert wird sonst können sie nicht
das rückgrat der bekämpfung der pandemie
sein und dazu gehört ja auch eine
adäquate bezahlung der mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter in den gesundheitsämtern
dritter großer bereich altenheime wir
haben jetzt viele erfolge erzielt beim
impfen der hochbetagten menschen die in
den altenheimen wohnen wir brauchen aber
eine weiterführende strategie was ist
mit den menschen die jetzt neu
aufgenommen werden die noch nicht
geimpft info gibt es da das konzept das
flächendeckend sichergestellt wird dass
derjenige der neue in einem altenheim
aufgenommen wird auch geimpft wird wie
führen wir die test strategien weiter
es reicht ja jetzt nicht zu sagen alle
sind geimpft und alles ist gut und vor
allen dingen müssen wir eins machen und
das habe ich eben schon mal gesagt und
das ist das große problem was wir in
dieser pandemie gehabt haben warum sind
so viele menschen in den alten und
pflegeheimen gestorben was ist dort
falsch gemacht worden und zwar nicht um
billige hier wird auf die finger zu mit
dem finger auf irgendjemand zu zeigen
sondern um die dinge auch in die zukunft
besser zu lösen und vor allen dingen
auch eine höhere sicherheit für die
menschen dort zu erzielen
vierter bereich impfen ja wir schaffen
jetzt mehr impfstoff das ist gut
wir brauchen eine zweite sache wir
brauchen ein besseres impftermin vergabe
management was in einigen bundesländern
in den letzten wochen passiert ist das
80 jährige über 80 jahren in
telefonschleifen tagelang fest gehangen
haben dass sie in online schleifen fest
gesessen haben das ist nicht akzeptabel
und das ist würde und respektlos
gegenüber den alten menschen in diesem
land und wenn wir über das thema impfen
reden dann müssen wir uns auch darauf
vorbereiten dass diese pandemie nicht
vorbei ist dass wir vielleicht nach
kämpfen müssen dass wir noch mal impfen
müssen dass die nächste pandemie kommt
und deswegen brauchen wir eine
impfstrategie 20 22 und 1 haben wir
gelernt
bei aller wertschätzung für
globalisierte wertschöpfungsketten
wir brauchen eine im produktionsalltag
ii innerhalb der europäischen union
wenn wir nicht in der lage sind unseren
impfstoff selbst herzustellen
dann werden wir immer abhängig sein von
anderen regierungen von anderen regionen
und dafür ist die frage zu ernst und
mein thema impfen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen möchte ich auch noch einem
punkt hinweisen
wir tun ja immer hier so als wenn das
hier hat es zu langsam ist und nicht
schnell genug geht und das mag
vielleicht auch richtig sein aber die
meisten länder in dieser welt impfen
noch gar nicht insbesondere
schwellenländer insbesondere länder in
der dritten welt und ich glaube wir
haben die verpflichtung die moralische
verpflichtung dass wir auch impfstoff
weltweit zur verfügung stellen und wir
sollten nicht nur an uns denken sondern
wir sollten auch an die welt denken wenn
wir über das thema im
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es
gibt noch einen weiteren punkt und da
können wir nicht warten bis die pandemie
vorbei ist wobei ich sowieso die
befürchtung habe wenn die pandemie
vorbei ist dann werden wir uns wieder
anderen dingen zuwenden und nicht den
katastrophen nicht den dingen die auf
uns zukommen können denn diese pandemie
wird nicht die letzte katastrophe seien
sie wird nicht die letzte pandemie seien
die nächste katastrophe kann im cyber
bereich stattfinden können klimafolgen
sein wie dürre wie hochwasser und viele
andere sachen
und wir haben eigentlich die mechanismen
dass wir eine risikoanalyse machen ja
wir hatten auch eine risikoanalyse zu
pandemien aber wir haben sie nicht ernst
genug genommen und dementsprechend
müssen wir uns intensiver auch mit einer
katastrophenvorsorge beschäftigen wir
haben auch nicht die gesetzlichen
grundlagen ich bin der meinung dass der
deutsche bundestag sehr sehr gut und
vernünftig mit der sache umgegangen ist
dass wir gesetzliche grundlagen in
kurzer zeit geschaffen haben aber wir
müssen uns grund ständig damit
beschäftigen was ist denn bei nationalen
notstand
wir haben eine notstandsgesetzgebung im
wesentlichen für den verteidigungsfall
aber wir glauben doch alle nicht also
dass die gerichte große katastrophe in
diesem land der verteidigungsfall sein
wird sondern das wird was anderes sein
und ja wir müssen das verhältnis
exekutive und legislative auch klären
und definieren und zwar für alle
katastrophen und für alle nationalen und
europäischen notstände und wir müssen
meine lieben kolleginnen und kollegen 1
machen
wir müssen wir müssen uns besser darauf
vorbereiten wir haben super
katastrophenstäbe in den einzelnen
landkreisen und in den städten
wir sind super regional aufgestellt mit
den feuerwehren mit den
hilfsorganisationen aber die bund länder
koordination die operative bund länder
koordination bei katastrophen 24 stunden
7 tage in der woche ständige
katastrophenstäbe stäbe die auch üben
meine damen und herren die bundeswehr
hat 70 jahre geübt dass irgendwelche
panzer an unserer grenze stehen sind
gott sei dank nicht gekommen wir müssen
katastrophen üben wir müssen
automatismen schaffen dass wir mit
diesen katastrophen besser klarkommen
darum geht es jetzt um das muss die
lehre aus dieser pandemie seien
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
insofern haben wir sehr sehr viel noch
zu tun und wir sollten das angehen wir
müssen jetzt alles dafür tun dass diese
pandemie aufhört aber ehrlich gesagt
diese krise wäre eine vergeudete krise
wenn wir nicht daraus lernen wir müssen
lernen und einige punkte habe ich ihnen
aufgezeigt vielen dank
[Applaus]